foreign
Chicago hi Sue how are you
I'm doing great thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
um my husband is 62 and I'm 58. we've
been married 38 years we have no debt
and our net worth is a little over a
million
um 200 000 of that is in real estate 800
000 in stocks and bonds in 1997
um we were raising four little boys and
my husband went through leukemia in a
bone marrow transplant and so the only
life insurance we could get was a whole
life and it was a six hundred thousand
dollar policy I'm Dave and Rachel we put
in since 1997 uh ten thousand dollars a
year into this policy now what fast
forward
um
15 years ago my husband had a heart
attack and five bypasses longevity in
his family the men
um just historically do not live long
lives so here is our caveat right now
all the boys are through college married
we have 10 grandchildren and this life
insurance policy the cash value is now
around
240 thousand dollars
I am just my husband and I are trying to
make this decision he is still working
he has an income of about 80 000 a year
he hopes to retire at about 65. my
income a year after coved I'm a
Christian motivational speaker so my my
uh income dropped from about 50 000 a
year to now twenty thousand we are
trying to make the decision of whether
we cash in this whole life policy and
put into our stocks and bonds
portfolio give them the fact of his um
life expectancy what's the face value
240. that's the cash value what's the
difference yes sticks 660
000 right now
okay
um
wow okay
so basically if if he dies or no when he
dies we all die yeah when he dies I
understand you if the policy is in place
you will receive 666.
okay that means they're going to keep
240. so you really have a four hundred
thousand dollar insurance policy
correct that's really what you have Okay
um and so the swing is
do you need the extra 400 to live and
the answer is no
you don't
so if you cashed it out and put 250 in
there or if you keep it either one
you're going to be okay either way
financially speaking mathematically
speaking agreed
agreed okay so this really comes down to
um
a bet that you're making not based on
the past
but for four hundred thousand dollars
I'm gonna bet that I'm gonna put in less
than four hundred thousand dollars
before he dies
right mathematically it's it's very
cold-hearted but it's a math thing
okay and so it's um you know uh um
and what's the can she save another four
hundred still it no I'm saying she's
paying for a 400 000 life insurance
policy in essence they are paying okay
okay and um if he dies before you put
400 into it if you put 300 into it you
gained by a hundred
mm-hmm right and that's that's the math
and is it currently and it will be
forever ten thousand dollars
yes and that and that in our first um
since we got it we fund that first and
then our employee matching and then our
roths that's been our yeah well that
would not be my order of priority but if
we're just making bets uh at ten
thousand dollars into four hundred
thousand that's 40 years is it not
yes it is so if you're just placing bets
on the math you're going to keep it
okay it's a crappy product I probably
would have dropped it 15 years ago or 10
years ago uh and save that money and
quit then and I hate it I I think it's a
horrible product but at this stage what
it's come down to is if you're going to
get 666 upon his death which is a weird
number by the way but
um
but the uh if you're going to get that
upon his death then
um and they're going to keep 240 of
yours that's uh 426 difference uh then
he's got to live 42 years
before you don't come out ahead if I'm
doing my math right am I doing something
wrong
I mean 400 divided by 10 is 40 isn't it
yes yeah yes and so 420 divided by 10 is
42 years he's 62. so he's got to make it
to 104.
um probably not happening I mean I'm
probably not making it to 104.99 and I
got longevity in my family so you know
right but um and she go she comes out
better ahead doing that versus catching
it all out taking that 250 and putting
it in an investment yeah I mean that's a
very simplistic way of doing it okay if
we want to get one more level of
sophistication we could say the present
value of that money right in other words
were you to invest ten thousand dollars
a year how long before in at an 11 rate
of return in your stocks and bonds what
the market is returned how long before
you'd get to four hundred thousand I
don't have that off the top of my head
but it's probably still
20 years
right so if if I'm tracking with you
right because this has been a dilemma
for me you know we're pretty financially
Savvy we did Larry Burkett before we
heard of Dave Ramsey and have done the
envelopes before they were cool and I I
think about if I pull out or we I'm
sorry pull out the the cash benefit of
240 000 approximately and I invest that
plus I'm adding I'm freed up ten
thousand dollars a year
right your your equation is more of
complete than mine
it kind of swings this pendulum the
other way well you got to get if you do
that you got to get to 666 but you'd get
there in with the 250. seven years six
years
exactly so what you got me you got me
you didn't need me I needed you
okay oh yeah you're exactly right you're
exactly right I left a variable out of
that oh wow that was dumb okay you got
it you're exactly right no you're
exactly right
um yeah yeah so what I would do is is
run the couch sit down with your
investment advisor and run the
calculation if you invest it your
current rates of return on your
Investments 250 plus 10 000 and how
quick do you get to 666. that's the
equation and if it's at 11 I think
you're there in about five or six years
is what I think it's going to come out
I'm doing that in my head but I'm not
far off
um so yeah I am gonna cash it out good I
feel better because I hate those dead
gum things I know ah I was having
trouble keeping it so you can take his
job
push your motorbike Christian
motivational speaker yeah you can you
know we got we have a need for you you
also do math